Chad Lindberg: And then you feel it.
I can always feel…
there will be like a hush behind me, you know
what I mean?
People will be talking and there will be this
hush and you feel that people are saying something
about you.
And especially now, people can get on their
phones and they’ll be like “Hey, Chad?
Your name is Chad, right?”
and I’ll be like “Yeah…you’ve got
your phone, right.”
Film Courage: I know this is like a weird,
creepy question but are you a people watcher?
I don’t mean like…[laughs] I know this
can be taken so many ways…but…
Chad Lindberg: I love people! [Laughs] Film
Courage: I know this can be taken so many
ways but in terms of studying human nature?
Chad Lindberg: Yeah.
Film Courage: Observing people is what I meant…
I am an observer.
I’m the guy who will be on the wall at the
party watching.
I’m not the guy who will be like “Hey,
everybody!”
I watch people.
And now it’s tricky when they watch you.
So it’s kind of an interesting dichotomy…is
that right?
Is that the right word, dichotomy?
It sounds right.
Use it!
Go for it.
Film Courage: It sounds right.
It sounds really good.
Chad Lindberg: Yes, but it’s interesting
when once fame sort of enters the picture,
then you have people staring at you.
So it makes it interesting.
Film Courage: Right.
For the times that maybe you feel you can
blend in more (which probably is not often)…like
let’s suppose you have a hat on or you just
feel you’re in a space where no one is too
celebrity focused, maybe in another town or
something.
What catches your eye about people in terms
of character study?
Because for me, I’ll see people at the grocery
store and [my focus] it will be on the person
who may not be that glamorous but they are
busy doing their own thing and I’ll be like
zeroed on on them.
Chad Lindberg: Totally.
The people who have like interesting tics
or walks or they have a disability, you know?
I’m fascinated by how they operate with
life and how they’re interact with people.
So I’ll really zero in on that because it’s
something.
I don’t know.
But yeah…people do catch my eye and then
I’ll try not to stare because it’s rude
to stare but I want to know.
And a lot of those things I have brought in
to different characters.
I’ll see someone doing something and I’ll
remember it from years ago and I’ll be like
“Okay, that might work for this [role].”
Observing is key to acting, you know?
Film Courage: And on the flip side, when the
eyes are on you and maybe you’re in more
of a public setting, how does that feel?
Do you ever feel pressure to be superhuman
in some ways?
Chad Lindberg: Yeah…you have to be…well
it depends on where it’s at.
If you’re at an event where people are there
to see you, you know you’re on, you’re
present and it’s a beautiful thing.
And then sometimes I will have my hat on somewhere
and I’m completely not even thinking about
it and someone will recognize you or it just
catches you off guard, you know?
And then you’re like “Wait, I am in the
public eye?”
I have to remind myself because I’ll forget.
Say like here in LA where it is kind of our
safe zone as actors in a way.
But still I’ll be at the Ralph’s and Ralph’s
is a local grocery mart in Los Angeles.
We love it here.
But I’ll be there not thinking of it and
someone will say “Oh…wait…you’re…right?”
Because when you go out of Los Angeles that
is when people get really, really excited
because they don’t see celebrities all the
time.
In LA we see everybody, you know?
And we’re sort of like Okay?
This is where ‘they’ live.
And we respect that.
But when you go outside of LA, that is when
people get really pumped.
Not to say that they don’t here but it’s
just a different thing.
Film Courage: Right…just because today we’re
in this new age of camera phones and people
get in fights on subways, and instead of calling
the police, they just take their phone out.
Do you feel any pressure that even if you’re
just at Ralph’s and you’re just looking
at the Rockstar [energy drinks] or whatever
and then you feel someone’s presence, do
you feel a little more self-conscious?
Chad Lindberg: Absolutely.
It does make you feel self-conscious when
someone is sitting there kind of…and I always
feel it whenever I go into some place now
because of being recognizable I will sort
of case the place before…I’ll go in somewhere
and be like “Okay, this person will probably
recognize me.”
And then you feel it.
I can always feel…
there will be like a hush behind me, you know
what I mean?
People will be talking and you feel this hush
and you know that they are saying something
about you.
And especially now, people can get on their
phones and they’ll be like “Hey, Chad?
Your name is Chad, right?”
and I’ll be like “Yeah…you’ve got
your phone, right.”
Back in the day it was like “Hey, Jesse!
Hey, Ash!” and I still get that a lot.
But now with the phones people can just go
in and type your name right away and figure
out who you are.
On the flip side, I think these [holds up
his camera phone] are weapons to.
We do have to be careful in these times because
I have had plenty of people all of the sudden
[holds his phone right up as if in another’s
face] just do this to me and I’m like “Do
you want a photo?” [and they’ll say] “Yeah,
yeah, yeah.”
[And Chad responds] “Well how about you
get in the picture and how about I take the
photo and we’ll both be in it?”
Fame is an interesting thing to watch people’s…how
they react to it.
It’s almost like some people can chill and
be cool and some people lose their bodily
functions.
It’s fascinating to watch.
And then some people will have a conversation
about you and they will be just as close as
we are.
And they will be talking as if you don’t
exist.
Like you’re an object.
It’s fascinating.
And I really try…I don’t take it personally,
you know what I mean?
I understand that is the inner workings of
fame and how it works and celebrity.
But a lot of times it can be invasive sometimes,
you know?
When people follow you into a restroom, you
know these things happen.
98 percent of the time it’s love and I feel
really, really fortunate to have been in projects
that people know and recognize me and people
are recognizing your work and that’s great.
Film Courage: I know I’ve heard Marc Maron
talk about how he could feel the room when
he went up on stage and tell what would be
a crowd that he could play to [as a comic]
and they would love and then vice versa.
And I think I’ve heard Nikki Sixx say the
same thing, he’s very sensitive to the energy
around him.
So when you feel that maybe the energy isn’t
totally friendly, do you leave?
Chad Lindberg: I leave.
I leave.
I’ve been in plenty of situations where
people have wanted to fight me because I’m
famous.
Because maybe there were people in the room
or a female that got excited and wanted a
photo.
And I’ve had several people over the years
want to come out and hurt me and I just (very
cooly) be like “It’s not me that you’re
upset with here.
It’s whatever you’ve got going on.
And it’s cool and I’ll leave.”
I’m not going to stick around if someone
wants to challenge me.
Because “Hey Hollywood” I don’t put
up with it, so…but you know it happens.
I always say fame is a double-edge sword.
Film Courage: Right…and I just have one
last question and we’ll move on because
I feel like I’m grilling you.
Chad Lindberg: No.
It’s alright.
Film Courage: When you felt that this [being
recognizable] change in your life because
I’m sure in the beginning you could go places
and people didn’t have their agendas whether
it was where they were in love with you or
jealous of you, whatever it was.
But when you felt it shift, how was that for
you?
Chad Lindberg: I remember the moment that
shifted and it was the day after The Fast
and The Furious came out.
We…my family and I had gone to see it in
a town near Seattle.
And we went into the theater, we watched it
and then we came out and I got mauled by people.
It was insane.
And I was like “Whoa!”
Because I didn’t expect that movie…my
Mom asked me if we wanted to have a film premiere
for The Fast and The Furious back home and
I said…I go “Mom no one is ever going
to see this film” because I was ignorant,
I was very young and I didn’t understand…again
we go back to being young and sort of having
these big hits.
You don’t realize what you have.
And that movie taught me that you never, never
know.
And I was so lucky to be a part of this huge
phenomenon.
And to this day people recognize Jesse left
and right, so I’m really fortunate.
And after I got mauled I went to another place
and got mauled again and then it just kept
happening and I remember at night…it freaked
me out so much and I was kind like…I was
crying…I was really upset and my Mom was
there and I’m like “Things have changed.
Things have definitely changed.”
And it was a tearful joy but also scary because
it’s like “Whoa…”
You feel the shift.
And it hasn’t been the same since and I’ve
learned to adjust and again I’m very thankful
for it, but it is an interesting position
to be in.
Film Courage: I think a lot of people don’t
think about that.
Because we’re in such an era of people wanting
to be famous whether it’s on Tumblr, Instagram,
Twitter, whatever but then there is this double-edge
sword.
But then you know the Chad that was the little
boy in the second grade and you know a different
Chad then the way the world projects [fame
onto you].
So it’s got to be an interesting thing because
you know yourself as Chad the human and other
people see you as Chad the actor or as superhuman.
Chad Lindberg: They do…a lot of people see
the perception, what they want to think of
you.
It’s not who I am, just what they see and
what they sort of want to put in their little
box of what you are.
And we do that I think with a lot of celebrities.
We just truly don’t know.
My favorite is when somebody says “So and
so is a jerk!”
I go “Really?
Have you ever met this person?”
I’m talking about celebrity.
This celebrity that is a jerk.
“Really have you ever met them?” [and
they respond] “No.” [and Chad responds]
Then you can never say that about this person.
You can’t!
Because somebody out there is saying that
Chad Lindberg is an jerk because I looked
at them a certain way or I didn’t hear them.
Am I a jerk?
No!
So it’s interesting when people say that.
I just think unless you know somebody in this
business, you don’t know them.
Film Courage: Sure.
Well I know Mickey Rourke was interviewed
and he said that LA was a town built on envy.
And I think that is true in many ways and
so I think sometimes that a lot of it comes
from that because we wish we were in their
[a celebrity] shoes.
But anyway…thank you!
Chad Lindberg: Sure.
Thank you!
And I love hearing those stories from guys
that have been around doing this for years.
I’ve been doing this a long time but he’s
been doing this a long time, too.
It’s interesting to hear similar stories.
Film Courage: Yeah.
It was a Piers Morgan interview with Mickey
Rourke.
And it was excellent.
I highly recommend it.
Okay.
Cool.
So we’ll move on from here.
Chad Lindberg: Awesome.
Question for the viewers: Who is the nicest
celebrity you’ve met in person?